well thank you for coming out can you
hear me okay
no do I do that here do I turn up the
volume here or elsewhere get friendlier
with the mic how's that is that
friendlier now as far as folding up your
chairs that sounds like unpaid labor to
me sorta no can we turn off the lights
or turn down the lights I'll just start
what I'm gonna do is run you through the
first day of the battle of the somme and
talk a bit about it
this is Lord Kitchener who was basically
the equivalent of the war minister in
Great Britain in the first part of World
War one
he was quite prescient he he predicted
that the war would go on for years now
many people thought the war was gonna be
over by Christmas you've always heard
you've heard that line but he knew that
what the war would require was a lot of
manpower so he built up a volunteer army
he started this recruitment process the
British professional army was really
small by Continental standards about a
hundred thousand people hundred thousand
troops and mostly in 1914 the British
Army was pretty much spent and in 1915
the territorials basically their
National Guard the British National
Guard took over and volunteers started
to come into play also by 1916 during
the Battle of the Somme the army was
mostly volunteers with remnants of the
professional and territorial divisions
this is General Douglas Haig he was the
chief architect of the Battle of the
Somme here is he's walking around his
chateau he every morning he was very
rigid he would take a four minute walk
around the Chateau
I mean precisely timed interesting men
vilified by a lot of historians and then
rehabilitated by a lot of historians my
opinion of him is is rather low but I
try to be rather neutral about how I
show him
there he is riding a horse he's in the
front there every day he would also take
a ride if he could with the 17th Lancers
which is a unit he used to actually
command because general Haig was a
cavalry officer and he or he believed in
the cavalry
in fact his idea for the Battle of the
Somme which was mostly fought to relieve
pressure on the French who were fighting
in Verdun against the Germans
his idea was after a massive bombardment
basically an unprecedented bombardment
the British infantry would take the
German lines the trenches and the
cavalry would go through and this
stalemate you've heard of the stalemate
of World War one the trench warfare that
the trench warfare stalemate would be
broken and the cavalry would roll up the
German flanks and once again it would be
a war of movement and for those who say
that some historians will say that well
Haig was wrong about certain things but
there was a learning curve and
eventually he got it and it's true in
1918 he won battles but he still
believed in the cavalry because even
after the war I'll read you the quote
after the war he wrote airplanes and
tanks are only accessories to the man
and the horse so he he definitely had a
different conception about modern
warfare this is a picture of British
troops coming up to the Somme front that
it was really one major road into the
Psalms so a lot of back roads were used
and a lot of material had to come up as
you could imagine the average British
regiment had about 1920 thousand
soldiers notes of division at nineteen
or twenty thousand soldiers and maybe 60
or 70 trucks or motorized vehicles and
five thousand horses so one of the
things I had to remember as I was
drawing this was draw horses because it
was still a horse horse was still the
main you know transport vehicle
this is an 8 inch howitzer famously I
told you about this barrage that was
going to be launched at the at the
German positions there were there was
one gun forever 17 yards of front it's
an often quoted figure it was a it was
an unprecedented bombardment but a lot
of the British artillery wasn't as big
as this most of it was much smaller and
also in 1916 a lot of the shells were
duds so about 30% of the shells were
duds
so this unprecedented bombardment was it
had a lot of bark but its bite wasn't
quite what it was advertised to be this
is a train the the the British laid a
lot of track before the battle to bring
as much stuff up as possible and here
you see an ammo dump where soldiers are
unloading things from the Train at this
dump and then those shells would be
taken to the guns and in the bombardment
1,500,000 shells were fired the Germans
before the infantry actually attacked
here I show the British soldiers going
to the front now as I mentioned mostly
they were volunteers and they were quite
enthusiastic about the war at this point
still the in the recruitment drives the
Kitchener came up with this idea of the
PALS battalions and so a lot of the idea
was you would join up with your pals and
so a lot of friends joined up from the
same villages and towns and units were
built around even professional classes
like clerks or there was an artist's
battalion for example and so friends
joined up together the troops I mean
perhaps one of the reasons they were
enthusiastic is a lot of them were told
that it would be sort of a cakewalk they
were told that the bombardment would be
so heavy that no German would be alive
in the trenches when they got there
and here's the bombardment it it was
planned to go on for five days and it
did then there was a rain squall and so
the battle was postponed by a couple of
days so the firing went on for another
two so at the very end of it the the
shells that were sort of put there for
the bombardment had to be stretched over
a couple more days this is one of
general Hague's beloved cavalry units it
came from India it was one of three
British regiment regiments of cavalry
that was put right behind the front
lines waiting for that breakthrough so
it could go through the gap
mostly I show Indian cavalry because
that was one of the units there but
mostly on the first day of the psalm it
was British soldiers it was probably the
most British of all battles there was a
Newfoundland Regiment but at that time
Newfoundland wasn't part of Canada it
was a self-governing colony around
evening time the soldiers who were meant
to go over the top would be coming into
the trenches being the ones in the first
waves would be given spades and wire
cutters as I show here the hope was that
because wire barbed wire was a very
effective anti infantry weapon or in it
was used extensively by both sides and
the hope was that this artillery
bombardment would would cut this wire
but it was it really varied in places
and and these soldiers would get to the
wire and supposedly they try to cut
through it so that their comrades could
go through night falls the soldiers try
to get some sleep some in some places
the trenches were so crowded that the
soul some soldiers spent the last night
on their feet now on the left of this
illustration or sort of where you can
see the barbed wire there at nighttime
the British British soldiers would have
gone out and cut a hole in their own
barbed wire in other words the barbed
wire in front of the British trenches
because obviously you need a place that
the your troops can go through
the background I'm showing the
bombardment and we're getting toward
morning now and in the last 60 minutes
or 65 minutes
the British intensified their
bombardment now it's it's around 7:20
a.m. on July 1st 1916 it's a bright day
it's already sunlight and you see
bombers they're basically grenade
throwers they would they would take a
pouch of grenades and every soldier
would take a couple of grenades with him
to give to these throwers when they got
close to the German lines the average
soldier had a pack or equipment that was
about sixty to sixty-five pounds they
were going over with sixty to sixty-five
pounds of equipment at the bottom left
you'll see soldiers having their rum
ration because it was standard in the
British Army in a major attack that they
would drink tea laced with rum or just
straight rum and according to Martin
Middlebrook he wrote a great book called
the first day on the Somme some of the
soldiers went over drunk I guess you
self-medicate before a major battle on
the right you see them fixing bayonets I
mean the idea was they would close with
the Germans and then cold British steel
would you know prevail just before the
troops went over the British exploded
large mines under the German trenches
these mines had been prepared for weeks
or months you know obviously there were
miners in the British Army and they
would have tunneled they tunneled under
the German lines and then exploded these
and some of the larger ones were heard
in England this one the the Hawthorne
mine it blew it blew debris 4,000 feet
into the air
so the mines went off and then there was
silence and of course the whistles blow
and they the British troops start going
over the top and I show an officer there
with his browning service revolver and
what's sort of interesting about the
First World War is that the the
not the high command but the junior
officers like the lieutenant's and the
captain's they led from the front and
throughout the war and including of
course the Battle of the Somme they had
a higher casualty rate than the average
infantry men so and the officer class
was generally from the aristocracy
basically often very well educated
graduates of Cambridge Oxford you know
they came out of Eden the high command
didn't have great confidence in the
volunteer army most of these troops were
seen combat for the first time so they
were told to to line up outside their
own barbed wire and move sort of
Napoleonic style in a row toward the
German lines the the the high command
didn't want a disorganized advance and
they were told to walk they were told
not to stop for anyone who was wounded
that the wounded would be picked up by
stretcher bearers later there were two
or three paces apart and these lines
move toward the the German positions
about a minute apart from each other so
there were just rows of infantry this
was the idea rows of infantry moving
toward the German trenches now I I've
talked about this bombardment the
Germans were very defensive minded in
this at this particular time and they
had dug very deep dugouts 4050 feet
below ground most of the soldiers were
taking shelter from this bombardment and
their machine-gun posts their
machine-gun positions were often
concrete reinforced and it would have
taken a direct hit to knock them out the
British on the other hand actually never
wanted their soldiers to be comfortable
in the trenches they never wanted their
soldiers to feel sort of have a
defensive mindset so the there were
dugouts but they were just a few feet
below ground usually for officers and
most of their soldiers and their
trenches would have just sort of dug a
hole into the side of the trench or or
sheltered with a cape so these soldiers
begin to
move out meanwhile many Germans have
survived they they hear the silent it's
silent the the British barrage has gone
further to the rear of the German lines
so now these soldiers are these Germans
are Manning their machine-gun posts and
they just start cutting down the rows of
British soldiers like like a scythe
basically and then the German artillery
begins firing into no-man's land it
basically puts up a wall of shell fire
and in the first hour of the Battle of
the Somme it's estimated that the
British incurred thirty thousand
casualties of which ten thousand were
deaths and just to put that into
perspective that's more than the amount
of American servicemen killed in Iraq
and Afghanistan combined and that's in
the first hour the Germans would have
trained their machine guns right on
those openings at the in the barbed wire
that the British soldiers were going
through so many of many British soldiers
lost their lives right as they got to
got out of the trench and were clumped
clustered together
the Germans also began firing into the
British trenches which were packed with
troops waiting to go over the top in
subsequent waves and many British
soldiers died or wounded before they
left the trenches when someone died in
the trench they would just throw them
over the over the side
obviously with with the wounded in the
trenches the stretcher bearers were
coming and trying to get them out and of
course there were scenes where soldiers
trying to move forward and stretcher
bearers of trying to go back and in some
cases sort of at the top right the
stretcher bearers actually got out of
the trenches and walked across open
ground because it was just faster to get
someone to medical at medical care
this is a battalion aid post it's where
basically light casualties would be seen
to an ordinary basis day to day basis
and these were obviously just very
quickly overwhelmed you'd have one
medical officer and a few orderlies so
most of the casualties obviously were
just sent just get to the rear and here
I show soldiers now wounded soldiers
coming out of the trenches the walking
wounded he as I'm showing here were were
basically told just to keep walking to a
casualty clearing station which could be
miles behind the front so they they
helped each other get to the rear the
more seriously injured would be put on
ambulances either motorised ambulances
like this one here or horse avenue
ambulances as again there were many many
horses were used in this sort of thing
this is a casualty clearing station
where surgery could actually be done and
they were done in these tents but as you
can imagine the overflow of casualties
meant that not everyone could be treated
right away so they began just laying out
the wounded in the fields and many died
untended here I show a soldier going
through the effects of one of the
dead.the the British would have dug
graves right by the casualty clearing
station sort of pre dug them knowing
that there would be casualties that
wouldn't survive their wounds
and so the book basically ends in the
grave with soldiers being buried there
when they had when they were ID'd their
names would be painted on a temporary
wooden cross just to know where the body
was so after the war or whatever they
could figure out what to do with those
with those bodies so in in the on the
first day of the psalm I mentioned
figures before but total on the first
day of the psalm the British had fifty
seven thousand casualties of which
21,000 were fatalities and so the
casualties the casualty rate was
basically one out of every two soldiers
who was thrown into the battle that day
so you can see why the Battle of the
Somme really hovers over the psyche of
the British nation the the battle went
on for another four and a half months
and about a million two hundred thousand
people were casualties in the battle on
all sides because the French were also
involved and including the Germans too
so that gives you a brief overview and I
would be happy to take your questions if
you have any yes the psalm is it's in
eastern eastern france basically by a
town called a men it's hard for me to
describe it exactly i can probably point
it out on a map it's it's eastern part
of france the frontline ran ran through
belgium and into eastern france and then
all the way down to the swiss border yes
your book your illustrations call to
mind a book called bird song by
sebastian folks have you read that book
I haven't read that book you should I'm
looking at this and I'm seeing
everything there was an image that was
conjured up by Sebastian folks I think
you would find it well well what's
interesting it thank you for saying that
it's interesting because there are you
know I spent some time in the Imperial
War Museum looking at the photo archives
there and there are many great pictures
but they're very
a few pictures of of combat and the way
I could get those images was by by
first-person accounts of the battle but
also some fictional accounts there's a
great book called her privates we by
Frederick Manning for example and you
know it's like when you're reading prose
you get images in your head well
basically what I did is I got I took
those images floating in my head and and
tried to put them on paper okay well
good that that okay
yes definitely you get a lot out of
fiction and this first-person accounts I
think we're using the microphones so if
you want to come up okay
well go ahead sir while we're waiting
inspired you to write this or to do this
production I'm familiar with many of the
photographs in the Imperial War Museum
and the detail that you've captured is
exquisite and your knowledge of the
battle is equally so and I'd like to
know what it was fired you and how you
ended up doing the work as you've done
what how did that all come together
alright well I've spent a lot of time
thinking about the Battle of the Somme
in the First World War I I grew up in
Australia and in Australia World War one
really figures also very heavily into
the national consciousness because of
the Gallipoli landings and I remember as
a boy on Anzac Day the day they
commemorate those landings class would
stop and over the loudspeaker which we
call the wireless they would broadcast
these stories of soldiers from the First
World War
so it's sort of in your head in that way
but then I read about it quite a bit as
a boy too and I was I mean I had that
little boys fascination with stuff like
biplanes and you know the the gas masks
they were wearing I mean it all looked
so surreal and it sort of intrigued me
but horrified me too especially even as
a kid reading about no-man's land and
what that meant literally I mean as a
boy no man's land you take the words
literally it means like no man
can be in this land and and so that sort
of stuff just pulled me in but at the
same time when I began to realize that
armies just battered each other over and
and gained almost no ground that that's
sort of horrified me I mean in 1915
hundreds of thousands of people died and
eight square miles were exchanged which
is really shocking to think that people
would be thrown into this sort of a
furnace later on I mean my interest went
to so far that I actually hitched
hitchhiked out to the Somme battlefield
and spent about three days camped out
there just reading tombstones
it's very poignant because families were
allowed to have an inscription on the
the tombstone of the departed person
maybe ten words and what can you say in
ten words and most were very sort of the
same the same the same but every now and
then something sort of stood out where
someone tried to say something different
and I spent time in Flanders also doing
the same thing so it stuck with me for a
long time and actually what happened is
I was in New York with I was living in
New York with a guy named Matt Weiland
and we both have an interest in World
War one this was 15 years ago and he
said wouldn't it be great if you drew a
panorama of the Western Front and I just
sort of forgot it but 15 years later he
calls me up and now he's an editor at WW
Norton and he said would you be
interested and I thought about it and I
thought I don't want to do a panorama I
but I do want to do a narrative and I
thought about the Bayeux Tapestry
and how that's a narrative and it's also
read in a way you read it from left to
right it tells the story of the Norman
invasion of England and you know it
shows the ships being built crossing the
channel and then the Battle of Hastings
so to me I already had a template for
the idea sure thank you
hi thanks I really appreciated your talk
and with these wonderful illustrations
and drawings to things I was curious
about the the
the sources for the pictures themselves
you know and maybe you'll tell us if you
haven't already I got here a little late
but photographs whatever and sort of the
process of creating you know these
wonderful illustrations you did and
second uh last night I was looking at
this calendar from this year and it had
it was based on the the art was of
paintings from the Civil War and this
kind of made me think about people were
different but coming right up there one
to the other without body armor or
anything like that and it's a little bit
of a loose question but just any
thoughts you might have about relating
World War one you know 1914 to the Civil
War of 70 years before something like
that well to answer your second question
first I mean it seems like there the
Civil War had many modern what we would
call modern aspects to it there was
trench warfare there were bombardments
sieges of cities there were there were a
lot of things that became familiar to a
greater degree in the 20th century that
we saw in the Civil War I think that's
true
now as far as the images like I said I
was in at the Imperial War Museum
looking for those sorts of details you
don't normally find in a photo book of
photographs of World War one some you
often see the same picture over and over
again in the different books but I
needed specific details of you know and
and even looking at the binders they
have this marvelous photo archive gave
me ideas when there's a whole binder on
mules you think oh okay mules so you
start looking through it and you realize
how much they would bring up mortar
ammunition and all kinds of things so it
actually gave me an ideas looking at
those archives the other thing I did
when I was in London I sat down with a
World War one historian named Julian
pukowski and he sort of answered a lot
of questions I had about very you know
the small details that when you do
questions you have when you're drawing
you suddenly think now how exactly did
they go over the top how would that have
been done
because I've seen images of people going
up all at once which isn't really
typical normally they would go up a
ladder because they have to get through
a little bit of barbed wire so they have
to go up up over the top through certain
areas and he explained a lot of that
sort of stuff to me so those were my
sources plus you know osmosis because
I've I've been reading about the first
world war I've shelves have books about
it but you know it's just sort of sunk
into my head and how thanks sure so I
think this is a related question I was
interested more in the drawing
techniques and the media and and also
how you came to decide on this accordion
fold book structure well I will credit
my edits format Weiland with that
because he's the one who suggested this
accordion style structure so he gets
full credit for that as far as the the
drawings and how I went about it
basically I I had 12 sheets of paper it
wasn't like one long drawing I was doing
it was 12 sheets about a yard long each
basically - I call them two plates or
two pages per sheet so the great
difficulty was at the beginning when I
didn't really know when how to start it
I I sort of I don't normally do rough
sketches which I don't advise any other
artists I mean I don't go by the way I
do things but I just don't like that
step so I normally compose directly onto
the page and so I'm constantly erasing
what I've composed because it you know I
didn't plan it out so it took a while to
get the rhythm right
I'd also prepared sort of an idea for
myself of how many pages I would need to
show the build up how many pages of
soldiers in the trenches for the battle
so I had a rough outline for myself too
and it took about eight months I
actually thought it would thought it
would take about four months but it's
actually it can take more time to draw a
couple of square inches in the in the
deep background then in the foreground
in the foreground you know your hand can
move a bit freely but in the background
these tiny figures I to use a magnifying
to get that that sort of stuff right and
it's very difficult to keep your hands
steady for the small figures so it was
pen and ink or Oh pen and ink yes
glorious pen and ink I don't know how to
use color I say with some shame so and
I've always worked in black and white I
I guess my question per turn pertains to
that as well I mean would any kind of
practice sketches or anything like that
I have about a page and a half of
practice sketches because actually I I
don't really know how to draw horses
that well so I sort of drew some horses
and just to try to get a feel for it and
I had books on horse anatomy to
understand some of that but again you
know I'm often practicing right on the
very board that I'm going to be inking
on so for better or for worse hi you had
mentioned the miners planting mines
digging under the German positions and
planting mines oh I'm sorry
and I was wondering I know that that
also occurred in the Civil War for
example in Petersburg at the Battle of
the crater and in that instance it's my
understanding that it resulted in
disastrous consequences because the
advancing troops sort of fell into the
crater and then were picked off pretty
uniformly did what were the results of
this mining expedition here well it
killed it killed a lot of Germans the
British the idea was they would take the
lip of the crater and then there was a
battle for that crater it became a
battle for the crater basically you know
the Germans also they knew something was
up they were digging counter mines too
and there are instances where the the
German mine and the British mine would
one would run into the other and they'd
be furious fights in the dark or in in
this sort of ill-lit in iLET tunnels so
you can imagine what that would have
been like yeah sure
hi um I've been reading a whole lot of
there's been a whole lot of graphic
novels that have come out recently that
I've tried to portray various historical
subjects whether it's the John Lewis
book about the civil rights movement I'm
thinking of the rebel woman book about
Margaret Sanger and and this and your
previous work and I was just curious
what do you think that graphic novels
bring to the portrayal of historical
events that perhaps other mediums don't
well I can probably talk about some of
the advantages but I never want to
disparage other other media because I
think every every medium has its
strengths definitely for me what what I
I think what I like about portraying the
past with your pen especially if you're
putting it side by side with the present
because a lot of my books I'll talk
about the past and and and also show the
present to me there's a real organic
relationship between the past and the
present and so much of what goes on
today is a result of the past so the the
less distance the reader has to travel
to get to the past the better and I find
that if you're if you have a drawing of
the present and you draw with the same
hand something in the past the reader
has an easier time of making that
transition you know when you see a
documentary film when they're trying to
portray the past they'll often use
actors to recreate something which
always seemed weird to me I mean you
know when they some documentary about
the Third Crusade and you see like three
people out in the desert and you think
wait a minute the Third Crusade at
thousands you can always draw a
thousands of people I mean the great
thing about drawing is you're kind of
you hire every extra you know it's just
it's just a matter of how many you want
to draw basically so that's that's sort
of its advantage and with photographs I
mean obviously you can there are great
photographs of the past but often the
technology of the photograph makes it
very clear that it's something in the
past so you get you have a modern
photograph of a place and then a
photograph a hundred years ago of the
same place it
but the technology of the one photo
looks so different from the new one that
it just feels like a completely
different era in a way that doesn't it
doesn't allow it to feel organic and
that's the that's the thing I want to
capture is sort of an organic connection
to the past thanks a lot sure so so I
have two questions okay
the first concerns the kind of
speciality that you have created because
when I first saw it I thought that this
is sort of a synchronic snapshot where
you're going for the Brit from the
British lines or from the people who
plan it Hague through to the soldiers
through to the event and then you go
into the German lines but that's not
necessarily the case because or is it in
as much as you know you end with the
grave at the end but those are not
necessarily German graves are they well
actually it never makes it to the German
lines what it what it does is it goes it
takes you through the British lines then
into no-man's land and then back to the
British lines and then back into the
behind the British lines I could have
shown the German lines in fact at some
parts of the front the British soldiers
actually made it into the German
trenches and after four and a half
months they penetrated as far as 12
kilometers you know which is nothing
really for the for the kind of losses
what I didn't want
in the illustration this is the artistic
angle I didn't want them to reach the
German lines because I wanted to
accentuate the fact that killing was
done from a distance in World War one
most people were getting cut down by
machine-gun fire which had quite a range
or artillery I think seven out of every
10 soldiers killed in World War one was
killed by artillery I mean people waited
in the trenches to die so that's what I
wanted to accentuate so so you know that
the follow-on question would be you
chose the British perspective and so
that comes out of your Austral very
anglocentric
and that comes out from most of my
reading is about the British I've read
something about the French
about the Germans but in the end it's
the British that swirl in my head and
you said that you know the British
nation but of course this is something
which is refracted through an experience
in Northern Ireland and it said
refracted through an experience in
Scotland and it's it's a question as to
whether there is a British nation and of
course the relationship of Australia to
the - to Britain is a very fraught one
so my question is how do you
contextualize this within the broader
range of the types of works that you've
produced in the past which have a very
strong moral dimension to it you know
you're sort of exposing an outrage of a
certain geopolitical kind you're
exposing exploitation you're expose
exposing cruelty and things like that so
how do you situate this within that well
that's a good question
most of my work has been journalistic
and most of it is about it's often about
very specific individuals I've met and
how they deal with what history or
politics has dealt them whether it's a
Palestinian refugee or someone in a
bosnian town or adalat in India I try to
bring out the person but I guess after
about 20 years of doing that sort of
thing
there are questions that began to come
to my head that can't really be answered
by journalism in a way I mean journalism
can sort of tell you about one people
and another people and how they're
contending over a land or this is a
result of that but in the end the
question I began to ask myself was about
the species as a whole why we continue
doing the same things and I realize this
when I began to think oh I don't really
want to go go to another refugee camp
what what am I going to find new it's
it's of course there's a particular
situation and those people have a
particular problem but on the other hand
I've questions now about the species and
so this was a way of standing
bit back almost in a disinterested way
and looking at humanity as a whole and
it gave me the opportunity I mean the
great the luxury of being in of drawing
is you get to think about what you're
doing so when I'm drawing those soldiers
going enthusiastically to the front I'm
really thinking about how people's it's
not just the leaders it's not just the
generals populace is get behind certain
things we're all responsible on some
level that's what I'm thinking about and
I'm and I begin to wonder about human
nature and so it's not that I have the
answers to it but this is sort of gives
me a chance to think about it somewhat
well then my question is a complete
opposite side of the spectrum and I was
wondering if you had any urge to fill
the back of the paper as well to fill
what the back of the paper the back of
the paper you know originally the idea
was we would reprint the exact
illustration and my annotations because
there are annotations in a booklet would
would be on the opposite side but a cut
there was a cost issue with that and
ultimately I kind of wanted to keep the
cost down somewhat so we decided to put
the annotations in the booklet is there
anyone else okay
I have a lot of thoughts swirling in my
head after watching this and it's really
good and one thing that comes to me is
how well you've portrayed the anonymity
of the common soldier of the British
soldier and how it was part of the the
Industrial Age that they were living in
that that so many of them were thrust
into this and expected to just go out
and die for England and one way that
they were able to keep recruiting so
many was because of censorship back home
and of hiding the horrors that were
actually happening at the time and I
think you've portrayed that that
factorization of of the soldiers and and
how they just went to their deaths not
willingly but with sort of a sense of
this is what you do for your country
until that started to change and and the
real news started getting back to
England about what it was really like
I've been to the battlefields several
times and they are just still to this
day just heart-wrenching and they're not
massive battle cemet the cemeteries are
not necessarily that big they're not
like the cemeteries of World War two to
the American soldiers they're the
Commonwealth graves are in small
cemeteries because people were literally
buried like you said right near that
casualty clearing stations or what have
you I have a relative who died on
September 25th going over the top
outside a village called Fleur they were
attacking gooda core where the German
trenches were and it's in if you go it's
just the most poignant thing even today
I mean you you certainly feel the the
ghosts and this war I think more than
any other changed English society in
ways that had never happened before and
the repercussions are still being felt
today and we're still battling
in places because of decisions that were
were made then so I just I find you know
your pen and ink drawings just a perfect
accompaniment to the the horror that was
there into the the anonymity and to the
the masses of soldiers who who were
killed and I also have to echo whoever
mentioned birdsong just an absolutely
fantastic book a good introduction to
the war and I'd also recommend anything
by Pat Barker about World War one the
regeneration of trilogy but thank you
very much it's most impressive oh well
thank you thanks for saying that you
know the British did print casualty
rolls in their newspapers which must
have astounded people you can imagine
them reading their casualty rolls also
the British produced a film called the
Battle of the Somme which is about an
hour long I think you can even watch it
online and in some ways I think it was
meant to explain what had happened and I
think the British got into this mode of
thinking of their losses as so in this
sort of solemn way it wasn't about
victory it was about all that they had
lost and I think after the war I mean
the interesting thing about world were
one I think on all size is people left
the front or the war it was over and
there must have been a big question mark
hovering over people's heads because
whatever you can say about why the war
started and that topic is we still talk
about well why did the war start it's
not it's sometimes it doesn't even seem
clear whatever the reason for the war
starting the way it was fought and what
was suffered just didn't seem worth it
at all and you think of that how people
reacted and then you think after World
War two
you know whatever happened in World War
two that's questionable from let's say
the Allied side by the end of it when
the camps were being liberated in a lot
of people's minds it was very clear why
why World War Two was fought there
wasn't that question mark that people
had people didn't feel let down by their
political leaders wondering what they'd
just gone through wondering why they'd
lost
so it's a very different I think rule
rule one you know it represents futility
I think to this day and the first day on
the psalm sort of epitomizes the
futility on top of that futility I am
very impressed with your point of view
which was elevated and how conscious I
mean I guess you might have thought
about being down on the ground with the
people but instead you hover just over
their heads and that's a very good way
to encompass a larger area and we want
to talk about that at all sure I had to
think of how I was going to how I was
going to show a large area and I knew
right away that I couldn't show it from
the ground level and I realize I had to
have to pull it up it was just a matter
this is what took me some time of
finding that right the right angle that
allowed you to see a lot of information
at the in the foreground but then a fair
amount that it you know we could go all
the way over to the horizon and see
things going on in the back I wanted
there to be a sense of space and
distance I was intrigued by one of the
very first things that you said about
was it vague yes apparently he was
initially vilified and then
rehabilitated could you say a bit more
about that right well some historians
contend that yes the first day on the
psalm the psalm was a questionable
battle but what they'll point to and
there's some truth to this is that what
what Haig did basically he wanted a
breakthrough but when it was clear it
wasn't gonna happen he talked about
attrition suddenly it became a war of
attrition you bleed the enemy more than
you're being bled and on that in that
sheer level there's some truth to the
fact that the Germans almost lost as
many as the Allies did at the Battle of
the Somme the Germans were defensive
minded but at that period every time
they lost a bit of trench they would
immediately counter-attack in the same
kind of straight-ahead over-the-top
fashion so they lost a lot of people to
Haig is given credit
for winning the last battle of the war
in 1918 but what I wonder about is if if
he had learned a lesson at the Somme
they talk about the learning curve for
Haig and for the British army but if he
had understood the Battle of the Somme
why did he basically repeat it the next
year in 1917 at Passchendaele which was
another enormous battle it's kind of as
someone describes I think Jeff Dyer as
the muddy version of the psalm because
it it right away the rain started and
the battles went on for months and with
an enormous loss of life so it doesn't
seem like he learned from the Battle of
the Somme then by the next year and in
1918 the Germans had sort of figured out
a way to break the stalemate of trench
warfare
the British were using the tank but not
effectively the Germans used this
concept of small groups of infantry the
stormtroopers that locally would make
their own decisions there was a lot of
delegation to very small units and it
was extremely successful and the last
year of the war they broke through the
British lines and came I think forty
miles from Paris and it was only sort of
sheer exhaustion that stopped the German
offensive and that's when Haig had sort
of at that moment his war of movement
which he he managed to to to win but the
Germans were exhausted now the Americans
are there so there were some things
going on that didn't have to do with his
genius anyone else are you fed up with
me okay one question over there you
wanna hit the mic oh okay
I just I'm curious
talk to creators who like a shorter
project in between the longer the you
know gene yang was talking about with
them you know working on boxers and
Saints and little collaborating to kind
of cleanse the palate in-between and I
was curious about Mesopotamia me if you
could tell us about that and what it was
like working on this you know a this
eight months compared with the that well
eight months is like a flash in the pan
because most of my books are five years
receiving seven year project so this
went quickly I'm I am working on a long
term project about Mesopotamia because
again those question marks hover over my
head coming from my journalism basically
and I I think about I began to think
about obedience to Authority and then I
began to think about Authority in
general and how did it how did social
hierarchy start and how did political
hierarchy start and I thought okay well
let's go back to the the ancients to
sort of figure that out so what I've
been doing is uh interviewing
archaeologists because I'm never gonna
become an expert but maybe I'll read
enough to sort of be able to ask
relatively intelligent questions of them
so that's what I've been doing with that
and that'll probably take some time but
as far as cleansing the palate goes I'm
working on a satire that's short and
very different from anything I've done
in in decades and hopefully it'll be
sort of funny but very dark and I won't
say much more about it you hint even in
the vaguest terms what your satirizing
or I'm realizing the last few American
administration's basically
because to me they all blend together
this isn't that purple of your graphic
novel but it's more question about what
you learned about the soldiers at a
certain point I think it's in the French
army there's a rebellion at the front
line
that's what's it what's the history of
that and how did they put it down
well you're referring to I think the
Nivelle offensive I think it was in the
spring of 1917 this sort of hotshot
young French general he launched this
attack and French soldiers were cut down
in droves and many units in the French
army basically mutiny
they said we're not going into the
trenches and or if they did go into the
trenches they would bleat on their way
just to make it clear that they knew
they were being led to the slaughter the
way the French army put it down was by
executing a certain amount of men in the
units I think some at random
interestingly the British executed about
320 or 340 people and the German army
only executed about 45 or so during the
war we usually think of the Germans it's
really hardcore but but anyway that's
how the mutiny was put down but you
could say four major offensive actions
the French were not really in it they
fight defensively but you can't really
think of a major I can't think of a very
major French action after after the
mutiny of course the Russian troops
melted away by the time of the Bolshevik
Revolution and Australia to its credit
the voters turned down conscription
because they were there was a referendum
they were - two of them and so they
turned down conscription anyway um
actually I was wondering speaking of
Australia how you self-identify
everything says you're a malt born in
Malta but if you grew up in Australia
now you live in the United States right
do you identify as a man of the world
thank you more about a particular school
of cartooning you know to me like my
passport is someone else's affair that's
like that's what this guy needs to see
you know I have to he needs a category
so for him on Maltese because I still
have a Maltese passport but I think I
feel most comfortable in America just
because I've lived here long enough
that's the truth anyone else or maybe
we're done one last question
No going once going twice fold up your
chairs
[Applause]